foreign
it is an honor for me to invite her
majesty Queen ramonda daughter of
lumumba sovereign ruler of the kingdom
of wakanda
Mr chairperson
I believe I speak for all the member
states here
when I say that I am deeply disappointed
in wakanda's Failure to stand by
promises to participate in global
efforts to tackle International
challenges to share resources and full
cooperation concerning vibranium La
France
and now give the floor to her majesty
Queen ramonda
it has always been our policy to never
trade vibranium under any circumstance
not because
of the dangerous potential vibranium
but because
of the dangerous potential of you
foreign
Ty here
but we know what you whisper in your
Halls of leadership and in your military
facilities
the king is dead
the Black Panther
skull
they have lost their protector
is our time
[Applause]
America
what is your spirit should it gave me
this to try
no I like them better our whole mother
gave us
elegant and
it will not change under my watch
last night there was another attack on
one of our Outreach facilities
proof of the involvement of a member
state
is being uploaded to your mobile devices
as we speak
and as for the identity of the attackers
[Music]
let our gracious response to this
incursion
be an olive branch
further attempts on our resources will
be considered an act of aggression and
met with a much steeper response
we're born the loss of our King
but do not think for a second
that wakanda has lost her ability to
protect our resources
we are of the ongoing efforts by some to
find vibranium outside of wakanda
and wish
best of
[Music]